foreign
Gotham Knight's gilded city is about
Batman's last big case with the entire
bat team a mysterious epidemic breaks
out in Gotham City what you learn is
that there was kind of a precursor to
this epidemic in Gotham City in the 19th
century Disneyland
historical feelings down just a few my
zones
what I wanted to do with the storyline
was explore the past and really see how
even more than 100 years ago the court
of owls had their claws in Gotham City
not only that there was another Mass
crusader
The Runaway is a character who fights
for the little guy right for the
ordinary citizens of Gotham
um
the comic series is a prequel so the way
that these two pieces work together is
that we see Batman in his pot but also
at the same time he's dealing with a
crisis that no one person can handle I'm
Consulting on the game as well so I had
the benefit of knowing the full Arc of
the game while I was writing this series
there's some things that hopefully will
pay off if you read and play both things
foreign